the U.S Coast Guard believes it's
recovered human remains from the
wreckage of a submersible which imploded
in the Atlantic Ocean killing all five
people on board debris from the Titan
Saab which was on route to view the
Titanic was pulled ashore in Canada
U.S medical officials will now begin to
analyze what's been found our U.S
correspondent James Matthews has the
latest
they brought back what they could find
this was debris retrieved by Salvage
teams from the seabed at the site where
the Titan imploded the U.S Coast Guard
said presumed human remains were found
within the wreckage it will be analyzed
with a view to establishing a cause of
death both of them so excited
so terribly excited about
going to see the Titanic families have
spoken of their grief following the
tragedy this was a memorial service held
by the family of Suleiman and shazada
wood they were among the five men on
board the Titan submersible
the wreckage brought ashore in
Newfoundland Canada will be a focus for
a U.S Coast Guard Marine Board of
Investigation its chair Captain Jason
newbar said in a statement
the evidence will provide investigators
from several International jurisdictions
with critical insights into the cause of
this tragedy there is still a
substantial amount of work to be done to
understand the factors that led to the
catastrophic loss of the Titan and help
ensure a similar tragedy does not occur
again you go down and with every 10
meters or 33 feet you feed you add one
atmosphere of pressure I am surprised
that that there are Remains the evidence
collected will Aid inquiries that have
far-reaching implications not just for
the Titan tragedy but for the future of
Adventure tourism the like of which went
so catastrophically wrong on this trip
James Matthews Sky News in Washington